[Music]
thank you for joining my session about
natural language processing and chatbox
and a little bit of machine learning so
quickly a little bit about me I work for
Oracle I'm a Solutions Architect or
consultants working Oracle being there
for out five years and my my core day
job I focus mainly on Oracle
technologies B but I've also been
studying data science for the last three
years mainly through online courses with
Coursera and so on it's mainly our based
that I'm getting more and more into the
Python world so mapping all my learnings
in are across item and home life yet
married with two children both children
learning Python at an early age would be
pleased to hear and my real passion in
life is fencing so I used to compete the
Great Britain and that's still something
I spend as much time as I can doing okay
so I mean why are we talking about chat
bots I mean I wasn't even chat BOTS were
not in my mind six months ago but there
just seems to be an extraordinary amount
of hike around chat BOTS at the moment
not a day goes past where someone
doesn't talk to me about chat BOTS or
some new initiative of that chat bot and
this is not a real Gartner slide I just
I saw you on Twitter and I just pinched
it because I felt it was quite
appropriate really and I I guess I
reckon we're at that peak is it inflated
expectations but I'm surely a little
bottom out and then we end up will end
up with some kind of useful applications
so what are we going to cover today well
first of all I'm going to introduce the
very basic working example that I've
called simple bot which doesn't use any
natural language processing or machine
learning and it's quite interesting how
well that does work it is based in
Python and of my sequel database and
really that just set some background
sort of the motivation for getting into
natural line
processing and why we need a bit of
machine learning to do anything useful
and the core of today I'm going to work
walkthrough for Python notebooks
introduced and introduction to the
Python NLT Kay toolkit using that to
tokenize text and extract parts of
speech tags and then starting to look at
how we can program it programmatically
analyze the grammar structure of
sentences and then finally a very simple
example of classifying sentences using
machine learning and then the idea is
towards the end I'm going to pull all
this together show these different
concepts and techniques that we've
covered into a basic working chat bot
which I've got deployed on a cloud
server and hopefully we'll see how it
goes but hopefully we can all connect to
it try chatting to it and well we'll see
how it goes that'll be a bit of an
experiment and I would like to set
expectations I think the important point
this is definitely this talk is broad
not deep I mean it was advertised as
novice you know if you're a long term
user of the NL TK toolkit and you know
you're probably not going to learn
something new this is all introductory
basic concepts today but we will achieve
something useful at the end okay very
quickly I mean what what do we need for
a chatbox server I mean we need a we
need a system for taking in human chat
natural language and responding back not
in code or summary technical summaries
but responding back with natural
language we're probably going to have
some sort of API interface web page
messenger api's like Facebook is one
people commonly use slack and so on and
the core of this we need a server
receiving all those different inputs and
outputs
a repository of knowledge that it can
refer to and a method of parsing that
language that's coming into it and
responding back in a sensible way so
we're probably going to need some sort
of machine learning to help us with that
and we'll need sums of knowledge base in
our temple server I say face so I'm just
focusing on the chat box server part as
you will see shortly I put no effort
time or thought into the sort of input
API i've got like a simple TCP sockets
client just so we can get multiple
people connected to it so on the basis
of that what did I do
I started by just trying to deconstruct
the chat box server wrote something in
Python with a simple well yeah thing
running around in the loop with a
multi-threaded server concept connecting
to a sequel database and some simple
command-line Python clients connecting
into it and I'll show an example of what
that looks like very quickly in a minute
but then the idea was then to sort of
build build this up a bit and we'll work
through the process of adding in the
Python ml TK libraries to process and
analyze language and also I do a very
brief example of using scikit-learn to
use a random forest model to classify
the sentences as they come in so we work
out what type of chat sentence we're
dealing with which is quite interesting
I think
so yeah I mean this is a trivial example
and it's something I stole from someone
else I just found a blog post by a guy
called Matthew Roddick I think and it's
sort of trivial but clever at the same
time and what he did was he just used
the database schema and sequel to create
a chatbot that gives the impression well
it does learn it learned by previous
examples and it just uses a bag of words
approach and based on the chatbots
output and then what the human responds
with it just Maps associations from the
chat box server chat bot sentence to the
words it received back and from that it
builds up quite a kind of if you just
use basic tack quite quite an impressive
ability to learn so the sort of thing
that you can do the sale at the first
hurdle I think I'm not connected to the
network am i sorry about this
I may as well do this because lots of
other things are not going to work if
I'm not connected
let's try that again
right
lightly you get you get the idea and the
sort of thing you can do is you can tell
it you could train it to know what a
what is a cat so what is a cat cat is an
animal that I don't know what do they do
chase is life so now we say what is a
cat but if we say what is a dog we get a
slightly disappointing response so it's
kind of a basic kind of trivial chat
that's all looking good but then
obviously we need to process our
sentence is a bit more intelligently
realizing that we need some real focus
on the object of that sentence and so on
so a little bit of a digression there so
what are the sort of problems we need to
try and solve you know we need to try
and identify the general topic of the
sentence just counting words but you
know you see a lot of examples
processing large bodies of text in
Python and other sort of analytical
languages and they focus heavily on the
sort of frequency of words and things
like that well obviously that's not
going to work very well when we break
what we've got is one sentence to deal
with and then you've got things like
take the sentence the cat is dead and
the sentence is the cat did exactly the
same words we've just changed the order
and they've got a completely different
context that is those are sort of
problems that the notebooks we're going
to work through and the processes try to
solve
and yes so yes we're going to dive into
natural language processing and focus on
what we need to do for and managing a
sort of human-computer dialogue system
and although mate I've mainly focused on
the Python NLT Kay which seems to be the
core most commonly used library for
natural language processing I think a
particular there's a lot of other
packages out there as well I think one a
particular note is spacey
if you have not such a problem for chat
BOTS or takers you tend to be just
dealing with small quantities of text at
a time if you're processing large
amounts of data then you might want
something written in C like Spacey and
also that it does appear to be quite
functionally rich as well and then
something that we're going to in turn
going to introduce later on I think is a
fantastic package the Stanford core NLP
package which is written in Java but
there are bindings in an ltk so it's
very easy to use actually sort of smiles
of acknowledgment in the corner is that
something you're familiar Wintel ok good
right well so I only scratched the
surface of it but it worked very well
for me
so and so really this is the call of
today and I have to admit I've not done
one of these before
I've tried looking at the format the
other people so I'm not quite sure
whether this is just a stand-up talk and
present or whether people are wanting to
do this kind of hands-on while I talk so
I'm going to work through some notebooks
you know cell by cell
and talk through it but if you want to
clone them now you can there's the repo
or you know you can just take a cup
later does anybody want me to pause
while you download them now which I
carry on feedback welcome I'll carry on
okay so
this one I mean I'll try and go through
as quickly as possible because it's kind
of really a preamble because we get into
the cool natural language processing
that we need for chatbots so generally
people when people are talking about
natural language processing they always
start from the point of a corpus and
tree banks and all the caucuses is just
a very large body of text to to develop
your natural language processing models
around so I think that the most
frequently referred to one that I found
at the brown corpus from Brown
University and these different caucuses
they tend to have different levels of
annotation and sort of semantic detail
or pre annotated against them depending
on how much research has been done with
it and taking that step further we come
to a tree bank which is parsed and
annotated so that for every sentence and
hopefully word in the body of text we've
got you know features and
classifications identified in it so
there's a lot of different corpuses
corpora and tree banks that bundled with
the NLT K which is very convenient they
don't all come down all downloaded
because they've just take up too much
space so you have to download the ones
you want and it's got a very kind of
user friendly way of handling that using
the NLT K download function so there's a
there's one very good one is the Reuters
corpus which i think is all the newswire
articles from 1987
didn't didn't think of making a note of
that oh well and so I've already got
mine downloaded and each of these come
with each of these corpses there's
various functions we can apply against
them so for in sweet we can look at all
the files that make up make it up or
more interestingly we can look at
categories that have been set in the
text by whoever created this corpus and
we can extract words and sentences from
them so I just do a quick example so so
before that I'm such a few more out this
various standard utilities in the form
of corporate corporate that you get all
data sets that you get from the NLT kay
and one of these is punk tea which is a
way of tokenizing by punctuation as a
part of speech tagger and there's also a
list of stock words which are just
useful tools that will refer to later so
here's an example with the Reuters
corpus so I can start by just looking at
what categories have been used to
classify the text and so there's 90
different categories and I've just taken
the first 10 and last 10 sample so you
can see that they've classified newswire
articles by do they can do they
reference barley trade wheat and so on
so if you're doing bulk text processing
and analysis that could be useful you
could look it so here oops
so here here's an example we might want
to just say extract all the newswire
articles that are the cover the category
trade sorry all the words and then the
sort of processing people might do is
then just you want to remove all the
stop words and then this will take a
while because of my very inefficient
coding I'm on going through the entire
142 thousand words and iterating through
it and ripping out all those stock words
give it a couple of minutes
and they'll be there while that's
running all we're going to do is use a
simple frequency distribution tool that
comes with an L TK and we can look at
one of the most common words in the
documents that are classified under
trade now we can also look at the things
like bigram is one of the most common
word pairs running
so this is kind of a preamble before we
get into the kind of core useful tools
that we're going to use for chatbot
processing having a large corpus of text
obviously is very useful for training a
model especially if the classification
happens to match the topic areas that
you want to classify your text by verts
kind of depend it depends whether one's
ready and available for you otherwise
you can have to classify your own and
what what we'll see later on is I just
generated my own set of text with my own
classifications to suit my own
requirements right good that's finished
so having stripped out all the stop
words whatever we found abouts what
we're hoping is a representatives set of
meaningful words in our text
and this is not supposed to take a long
time so much right so here we can see
that the top 20 most common words in
that text that classified as trade we've
got things like billion Japan Japanese
surplus deficit so you can see people
who want to build models to work out
which is this document likely to be
about is this newswire article likely is
about trade you could do that very easy
easily we've sort of distributions of
commonly occurring word counts and if
you you can do things like diagrams and
skip grams as well and I think in the
field of sort of rediscovery and text
you know document retrieval this is the
sort of thing people are doing so in
these articles about trade here were
seeing the buy grams are even more
telling trade surplus trade deficit
United States so you could quite easily
build a system for giving a you know the
probability of a document being related
to trade um yes please
yeah yes
so yeah that is the that is the
challenge so you need to find there's
I've referenced it in this notebook
[Music]
it'll happen there
I put a few links in here so you you'll
probably find the notebooks more useful
for the links and references than not
them my clumsy Kaling sky style that yet
we have a look at that you'll see here
are the corpora that you get with a
natural language toolkit as a lot of
them and it's a bit of a voyage of
discovery try to find out on that's
useful for your needs
so it before we move on or just very
quickly have a look at a tree bank so
this is a penn treebank where you get a
ten percent sample of that with the
latter language toolkit which is plenty
and in if I extract the words from that
and then what I've done here is I just
look at say the first ten words you can
see each word the first word Pierre and
then it's been tagged with a
classification and NP for personal
pronoun and then his surname or so
personal pronoun 61c d years n NS and
that tags just means it's a plural noun
and so on old as an adjective so every
single word in that tree bank has been
classified in that way and you can also
extract by sentence and you can see in
this tree bank what they've done is
they've also defined us of a tree
structure so which is must have been a
kind of a momentous piece of work to do
this but you can out of this if you
wanted to develop your analysis of the
different structures of languages you've
got something to work against so here
we've got at those are the root of the
tree s for sentence and then we'll talk
about what some of these things mean
later that NP for a noun phrase VP for
verb phrase and that noun phrase is
identified as the subject made up of
guy's name and so on and so on
so I don't want to spend too much time
on this
but other than just introducing the
concepts the vocabulary and you know
points of reference if you want to look
at it in more detail and this and this
is very useful when you I mean I was
trying to debug my slightly brain-dead
chat bot and get it to work a little bit
better being able to visualize the
structure of the grammar like this I
found very useful so you can just take
that past sentence and you run in I - in
Jupiter you display it this way and then
there's an equivalent method if you're
not using Jupiter it comes bundled with
it NLT Kay right so that's a very kind
of quick whistle top store whistle stop
tour of what a caucuses and a treebank
any questions on that before we move to
move on to the core topic which is
tokenizing and tagging text okay
so I mean all those techniques that's
great for kind of large volumes of data
but if we've just got a sentence coming
into our chat bot and we want to decide
how to respond to it appropriately we
need to look at things with it more of a
granular way so first of all we need to
break up our text into sentences and
then within that we all need to break up
that sentence into individual words and
we'll probably need to have some kind of
understanding of relationships between
those words if we're going to go beyond
just of counting the frequency of
occurrence of actual English words so
they this is generally known as part of
speech tag part of speech or paused
tagging so the default there's several
different ways of tokenizing text in
general and there's several different
tokenizer bundled with the NLT kay the
default one is called the Punk'd
sentence tokenizer and so what I've done
here is I've taken some text from
Ulysses because it's kind of nice and an
interestingly non non-trivial non simple
set of English text Donal wives used to
escape line feeds on the end sorry about
that
anyway it works so let's just have a
look at what that looks like if we try
and use the sentence tokenizer just
split it up into sentences so you've
broken it out line by line and you see
it's quite easily confused so I guess
James Joyce is using a exclamation mark
not at the end of a sentence there which
i think is valid I'm not an English
language expert and similarly any kind
of exclamations or dashes like that
confuses it so we get our sentences
split up in a way that would probably
really confuse a chatbot so
and this is just kind of like
illustrates some of the challenges we
have when you get into the real world so
even in that very simple example we can
see things going off so there's many
ways of tokenizing text into words
I didn't look at them all but I've just
focused on the ones that seem to be most
commonly referenced and what I've done
here is I've chosen three different
tokenizer so the default tokenizer
the NLT kay is based on the penn
treebank which we saw briefly earlier
there's also the word punked tokenizer
which is you can probably guess just use
punctuation and then there's the space
tokenizer which Punk which tokenize is
on white space and instinctively white
space would seem to be a good way to go
to me but actually by kind of my
experiment I'd say that the default n
ltk tokenizer is probably based on the
penn treebank
it's probably the best way to go so if
we just take a simple sentence like mary
had a little lamb its fleece as white as
snow
even with that single sentences we get
three different outcomes so for the
default tokenizer we've got it an S has
been split apart punked tokenizer has
splitted apart as well but it moved the
[Music]
apostrophe off and that's been
identified as a token in its own right
and then finally the space tokenizer
publicly because it just works on blank
space was kept it's all as one item so
that has an impact so as well as
splitting into tokens we need to
identify the parts of speech for each
totem that we've got and that's all
nicely handled for us with the poles
tagger
so if we take the totems that are
generated with the default treebank
tokenizer and stored in tree tokens and
we also look at the space tokens and we
look at the effect that has we can see
that for the default n l TK tokenizer it
has been identified as a PRP personal
pronoun s of the verb i think that's
correct if you use the space tokenizer
it is considered to be a noun which is
not correct so i guess that's just a
little illustration of why kind of ID i
start by just splitting everything up
using spaces and that can that can go
off course it's all these different tags
I've just pasted on into this notebook
to reference and obviously I'm going to
go through them all but you get the idea
just about every part of speech you can
think of is classified and also the way
they've done it all the noun all the
different types of noun start with in
and all the different versions of verbs
is start with a V which is good if you
want to do quick and dirty hacks with
regular expressions which is kind of my
general went way of working it works
quite nicely so yeah if you so if we
take the mary had a little lamb'
sentence
we've now tokenized it and we can just
extract all the nouns out of that
sentence mary Lampley so although that's
very simple we've moved on a great deal
from just looking at a bag of words that
are all equally that we can say actually
we want to pick out the nouns give those
extra weight
being in our consideration right for
this bit stemming and limit izing I'm
covering it because it seems to be a
kind of a core part of the domain have
to say I found I got very little
practical benefit from it and it might
be just because I was doing it wrong but
this is a topic of just stripping words
down to there I'm taking the suffix offs
suffixes off so trying to identify the
core word or trying to map that word
back to a kind of a core dictionary
definition and I think I think you can
sort of see instinctively or intuitively
why that'd be a very useful thing to do
and I think the challenge is that while
the tools that I tried just didn't work
very well so I've got very indeterminate
you know got very kind of variable
results with it in exact things so it's
three kind of stemming methods generally
reference the porter stemmer which I
think was the original NLT case tenner
something called the Lancaster stemmer
we've developed at the University of
Lancaster and then the snow balls demo
which is what what I can gather on Stack
Overflow and so on is what most people
seem to be using and that's just the
next iteration of the porter stemmer so
I think the best way to explain it is
just look at a quick example so if I
have I've got three spinners the port of
the Lancaster the snowball and sort of
where I got this sentence from has some
interesting aspects for classification
so if we look at the stem version of
those two sentences using those three
different stemming
method we get very variable results so
for instance only the Lancaster stemmer
has left Mary as Mary that has have
changed her name which could cause
problems two of them so one of them has
changed was to W a and ideally the sort
of useful thing this could do would be
to change lying you might want as in the
root of that would be lie but so here
the the snowball stemmer had a pretty
good go at when I was going the woods
it's changed going to go has changed
lying to lie so I take it back I'd say
the snowball stemmer does work
reasonably effectively
in other examples which I don't have
recorded here well for instance here you
know how its dealing with personal
pronouns changing changing people's
names is not convenient could cause
problems so limit ization send the sort
of idea but it's trying to refer back to
base dictionary words and here's those
2-cent sentences process using the word
neck limit Iser and
again it's okay that there are some odd
variations in it and I didn't really use
stemming or I started off assuming that
would be the the best way to go but I
found it difficult to get anything that
was dependable with it so I've left I'm
rushing through these because I want to
try to get to the end a complete package
something that can be used but I've left
on these I did quite a lot of other
stuff other than what I'm showing these
notebooks and I've just left some the
only really way to get into it is to
play around experiment met about and
I've just left you know my two pens were
tagged on the bottom of these notebooks
for ideas to explore but just in summary
you know where we've got to now so we
now we can tokenize text into sentences
we can go beyond counting the frequency
of actual words and classify words by a
type so we can identify features in the
text so and and that part seems to be
the core bread-and-butter what we need
for a chatbot but we want to get a bit
more sophisticated we that we need to
look at the grammar structure of a
sentence so not just is this a noun is
this a verb is this a personal pronoun
but you know what what are the important
nouns what are the relationships of
those nouns so what's the object of this
sentence what's the subject who and
who's performing the action what's the
topic and that is a much more tricky
thing to do so I start I started looking
at the what was available in the natural
language toolkit and it's got this thing
it refers to as the CFG class which
stands for config grammar I think now
this is just taken straight out of the
ML TK book
so actually I should have before
starting this I should have introduced
that there's something called the NL TK
book if you're interested in this I mean
that is a fantastic resource and that's
the starting point I would say is using
the in l TK book there's worked examples
yeah and and all of these topics are
covering our or most of these topics I'm
covering your in there but in some cases
I've had to kind of extend beyond the in
l TK book as well see so anyway this is
what this is what you get in the NL TK
book and basically you you build your
own kind of method of parsing grammar in
a text string like this this is their
example
but so what and so the root is
identified isn't it is s and what
they're saying here is that our root s
the whole sentence can be made up of
noun phrases and verb phrases that the
first rule and then here we're saying
that you know noun phrases can be build
up or out of determinate nouns or
determinate nouns with cotton or PPS
prepositions I think and so on so to
manually building up your rules in a
text string like this which I guess you
could extract from one of the tree banks
but unless I missed it that hasn't been
done and then mapping the words in the
sentence you want to analyze back to
some positives so that well let's just
see what that looks like before we talk
about what what it gives me the best
thing about this is the sentence in my
opinion which is I shot an elephant in
my pajamas which is an interesting
conundrum and so if we try if we create
this grammar and then we try using the
powder for that grammar against that
sentence
we'll see that we actually get to
grammar trees coming back because it's
not possible for it to tell whether the
elephant was wearing the pajamas or the
person doing the shooting was wearing
the pajamas but that's all very good and
also you can draw a nice little chart of
that congruence of grass relationship so
the observation made in the ML TK book
is that it's very hard to scale this
approach up for any large texts and you
know I'd agree with that and I was in
the market so not writing my own from
scratch I was I was looking for useful
tools to make this easy for me and after
looking around for quite a bit and
toying with various things I fell upon
the Stanford NLP core NLP software
package which is brilliant and it's a
huge topic I've only scratched the
surface of it very well-documented but
it seems to be very well supported and
the best thing of all those bindings in
Python and on TK so you can reference
the standard parser directly from within
NL TK so and I I would say if you're
going to be getting into grammar pausing
to take a look at it so to get that to
work there's a little bit of setup
involved and that's where we get into
some dependencies if you want to try
running these notebooks yourself so the
first of all first thing is you'll need
Java 8 installs and also you'll need to
start the Stanford core NLP package
installed in the form of a couple of jar
files and so then what I'm doing here is
a first of all just
import the binding to the Stanford
dependency powder and then I'm setting
up a path to the gr files and then you
can initialize it like this just
referencing the telling it telling it
where it's jar files are basically so
without any of that effort that we had
to go through for the NL TK version I
just call the Stanford dependency parser
half in this sentence it returns it
returns a result which you then have to
just tech to take the next item off then
what it gives you there we go good what
it gives you is as you can iterate
through a set of triples which is really
nice I think so
here so each of these triple we've got
sort of a route and a associational
relationship to a branch so here it's
saying I is related to shot of being the
subject an elephant is related to shot
of being an object I mean and that I
mean for me will go in a whole a whole
other world now of sophistication in
terms of language processing I'd say be
able to do that and you know from from
that point on you know where you take
that it's kind of may not get the same
direction as me I think I haven't really
explored how far you can go a long way
once once you've got that ability to
analyze and process programmatically the
structure the language and the
relationships of the words in that
sentence you can be quite targeted so
some of these
relationship definitions are kind of
obvious that's obviously a noun subject
as an object some of them are less
obvious they're all documented here and
this appears to be a collaboration
between Google and Stanford University
and so they explain what all these
different related dependency relations
mean where am I so
somebody have any questions don't ask
the fine laughing what's need to check
how long have I got it finds me a 5k
athletes in one life right good okay so
the most useful thing of all we can just
we can just find out what the root word
is in a sentence so in that case it's
shot so you know outside the field of
chatbots you know that means now we can
very easily sentence by sentence say
what's the topic of that sentence
it's about shooting
so and we can we can extract the tree
with a list format like that and we can
look at it as a graph
as well which is very useful when you
are trying to analyze more kind of
complex sentences and debug why your
particular text processing algorithm is
not working very well so if we take a
much more kind of complicated sentence
again going back to that Ulysses text I
mean that is a real mental sort of
tongue twister
whatever he watched the dark isolates
narrowing with Greaves - her eyes were
green stones it's very very poetic but
it does a very good job of picking that
apart and understand structure so it
decides that the head word is watched so
that's the topic and I think that seems
correct to me and then here's the
dependency graph so he watched and then
there's narrowing but with these
modifiers the dark I slipped and he
watched with greed and then we've got
the object eyes her eyes and then the
only bit that's slightly confusing is it
thinks he watched stones when in fact he
watched her eyes but that's a pretty
accurate deconstruction of quite a
complex sentence so if we kind of modify
our sentence I shot an elephant and we
just make it a bit more specific while I
was wearing pajamas then yeah we get a
nice I shot object in elephant and then
there's this kind of modifier while I
was wearing pajamas has been separated
off so that works very well
I mean I've come up with this toy
example here a very simple algorithm the
details based on that so just I you know
one of the most interesting things we
could know on a sentence by sentence
basis what's the core topic what's the
subject
and what's the object so I'm sure meant
for a lot of code so many of you could
do a better job than me but here's this
of an example of the sort of thing you
could do kind of a bunch of random
sentences flux from my mind bearing from
Ulysses through Oracle product release
information I mean this is a difficult
sense of pi data community gathers to
discuss how best to apply languages and
tools to continuously evolving
challenges in regards to screen but I
picked that off the PI data website and
a couple of thoughts on Arsenal so if we
run that through this little bit of code
which just like goes partly through the
triples or each of those sentences and
extracts out the topics subjects and
objects you can see first one we've
already seen this it's worked out the
subject is he topic is watched objects
narrowing isolates so when will the
Oracle 12-2 database Bruni so it's
worked out the topic is about release
and the subject is database coherence
it's about clustering which is correct
and the top and subject so you can see
that works even though it was a bit of a
crude approach I took it actually works
quite effectively if you just want to
take a sentence and say well boil it
down what's the sentence about what's
the subject what's the object
you know when we'll ask the level win a
match well the topic is winning the
subject is Arsenal the object is match
you know pretty good so you know this
gives us a way to programmatically
analyze sentences looking at their
grammar structure pick out a topic and
classify and we can also classify groups
of words based on how they relate to
each other so I'm sure that hopefully
being an interesting task to take away
you know look at my little toy example
use a standard dependency parser and I
think there's
quite a lot of mileage in there okay so
it's just some kind of interesting and
relevant is this at the right level
people I've never I've never presented
at an event like this and also I'm just
be interested in whether I'm kind of at
the right level covering the right sort
of stuff it's good okay so so given that
there's one aspect that we haven't
really covered and that is this of the
flow in the chat bot so what I didn't
really demonstrate at the beginning when
I showed us talking to that little chat
bot server is the challenge of if you
ask the chat bot a question you want it
to give you an answer similarly if you
tell it a piece of information you don't
necessarily want it to chat back you
just want it to store it if I'm sorry
I've taken the example of what if we
could use the chat bot become a simple
sort of FAQ server so we either stores
pieces of information or responds to
queries and then thirdly because I kind
of mocked this up and launched it on my
long-suffering colleagues and had them
all working with this chat bot server
the other thing I've noticed is that it
doesn't matter how much you tell people
this is just a chat box service very
very simple all it does this people
start chatting to it and they and you
know and because I was working with the
database I could see what people are
saying and they like going hey how's it
going man and are you a bot and what's
the weather like stuff like that and so
the chat bot needs to be able to not
only be construct the sentence in the
way we've just been talking through it
also needs to be able to work out what
type of sentence is there so I mean
that's a big big topic a big problem
and so I boiled that down into something
that's kind of manageable for
presentation and if we can just work out
is ascent of the question is it a
statement or is it anything else really
chat let's say but
that would be very useful so that brings
me on to the final Python notebook I'd
like to work through so here I kind of
until now really I've just been taking
excerpts
out of what's already in various very
good sort of comprehensive bits of
documentation whether it's the Stanford
NLP library or the NL TK Doc's or other
blogs and so on you know I saw a split
spin-off slightly into into my own crazy
world of my own approach of using a
generating features from sentences so
that we can apply a machine learning
models in and the focus of this although
I use random forests for this the
focuses of this is more a strategy for
generating features so that we can do
something useful and the and that and
that seems to be the challenge here for
dealing with a just a bunch of text so
yeah the process or the process we need
to go through is in this notebook as we
load some data in and that data is pre
classified so it is signifies learning
so I've taken a hundred sentences there
I think the mainly just typed in by
colleagues when we were messing around
this thing and each sentence I've
classified with a C for chat to cube the
question and ask the statement and then
it's how to come up with a method of
extracting features from that data so
that we can build and effective you know
we can use a machine learning algorithm
to build some sort of model for
classifying other sentences so and then
we'll so we'll do that we'll build a
model against the training data set
validate it and then we'll test out and
see how successful that is so to do this
this notebooks depended on some other
sense some other data so there's
sentences dot CSV
so I've just applied the link to that in
this notebook we can you once you see
the structure you can do your own also
to do some of the validation I've taken
some statements from the Python FAQ so
if you want to follow this notebook kind
of line by line then you'd have to
download that CSV as well and then most
importantly of all these features dot
this features Python module that I've
written which basically does a huge
amount of grunt work just processing the
sentences and then extracting the
features in the method I'm just going to
just using the method I'm just going to
under strive in a minute so you can
either if you just Chrome if you clone
this some github repos then you get the
whole lot bundled in with it as well as
my chat bot code or you can I put them
as a release in github as well so you
can just pull the individual series if
you want right so let's just go through
it step by step so we'll load my
sentences data and pull it into a
panda's data frame and so if you were
doing this you'd need to I'm done
anything kind of clever like a requests
get or anything like this it's usually
get the CSV put it somewhere local on
your laptop and load it in and set the
path appropriately so I've loaded that
data and if we just look at the first
few lines eleven lines so
sorry I don't know about the weather
statement that is a tricky question to
chat some of these classifications are a
bit dubious I'm saying done in a hurry
for me but I'm a pretty clear-cut if you
deploy in my sequel database in the
Oracle than what the rest sentence is
that's a question and this is clearly a
statement and Max is a mobile
application accelerator well clearly not
putting by me an Oracle product I've got
no idea what that is
even not to reading that sentence but so
that's the structure of the data set
we're starting from there's a hundred of
those and just in that sentence class
format so chapter 6 of the NLT K book
has some great kind of worked examples
of how to do things like naive Bayes
classification and so on and I suggest
just take a look at the ltk book and
works with examples so what I'm going to
do is something a little bit more weird
and wonderful and you know kind of
polite feedback afters whether you think
it works or not be interested in what
you have to say about it
it appears to work technically at least
so this is going to be how to explain
this clearly so what I've got here is a
little sort of sample bit of code where
I taking a sentence can a dog see in
color and why and then I've taken eyes
it and let's just print out the tags
that we get for that
so can MD a BT and then if I just throw
away the words and just extract out the
tag in the then that sentence turns into
just a string of pasta MDD T n N and n I
n and n so we've got some features but
then what I did is I experimented with
breaking it up into sequences of
trickles so the first triple is M DDT
and n the second triple start here DT
and then hopefully you get the idea and
there's all sorts of variations of that
technique that you can do to just build
up secret patterns that you can then
count for given sentence and then by
counting those we've then got some
numeric features we can work with so
what I did was I just ran that through
and bulk processed all my sentences and
extracted all the sent all the triples
for each sentence you and I just wrapped
all that kind of grunt work as I
described into a utility called features
and basically parsing a sentence and
it's at a dictionary of the features
it's identified so buried within that is
all sorts of stuff the most important
one really is gets triples which returns
the string like that
and
yeah sorry there's an example of it what
we do he passed in Canada green color it
returns our last so I run that through
all the sentences in my data set to get
quite a lot of data to process and then
what I did is I just loaded it all into
a sequel database so I got three hundred
and sixty different triples to deal with
that each triple eat each row
observation in the data table also have
the classifier C Q or s so here's the
kind of the breakdown the chat not very
fruitful for triple that I've got a good
you know reasonably good thread between
question and statements for the numbers
of triple items in the database then
lots more interesting it has then write
a query to break it down into groups so
this query is saying that there are not
going to run the query lie but there are
five occurrences of that triple pattern
and we only have them question
statements that's quite useful three
occurrences of that triple sequence they
only occur in sentence statements these
ones I've just manually highlighted them
in HTML to just try to explain in this
tool so these ones highlighted in gray
yeah we've got three d TN n and n that's
fine is Q but we've also got some of s
so they're not very useful so now that
was quite quickly I was able to identify
sort of ten sets of triples that were
common identifies four questions and ten
or so that were common identifiers to
statement and I kind of evolved this
technique sure
correct so yeah so the question was this
the counting of this occurrence of
triples is not specific to being at the
beginning or the end and correct in this
example is just does that pattern occur
in the sentence simple as that
I did I didn't just do this on those
features I also did the main exercise
those try to do classification without
any word count so the rule I set myself
is I'm not going to counter count
question words like where is why because
it just seems to be a flawed approach to
me you know but then you know all these
things it's a mixture of you know
science how can the guess work and luck
in the end and I think if I kind of step
back from this kind of artificial
exercise of just trying to do it with
triple patterns then I think the kind of
algorithm approach I Payton will go up
from being about 85% accurate to
possibly 95 like you know but that this
is a kind of a just one technique I'm
trying to illustrate I'm accent so the
the most fruitful methods were the
triples and also I did a I cheated a bit
just to make it a bit more active IIT
Tudor does a verb before occur before a
noun in a sentence close it so sentences
that have a verb before a noun
I think they tend to be questions yeah
that general hopefully could be roughly
what I'm doing
so just carrying that on I ended up
coming up with like my spoke Peters
generator so when I put in some
sentences like that
so can a dog see in color actually fails
on my triple school to get the score of
0and for the statement school which I
called s triple school look it's a
triple score zero so that hasn't worked
on the triples but we're lucky in this
case there's a question mark on the end
so I do count that's probably my biggest
cheat this whole thing I do count
question marks but this method does pick
up questions that don't have a question
so I'll do a demo later but I've also
got some other things here like cue the
combo I think there's some light as well
as triple though count doubles as well
there's some other combinations they
also help
so just take take that approach and
multiply it out for about ten different
features is what I've done but I don't
want to go through it or model so that I
mean that was a lot of work I mean I
think that was that a week's worth of
hacking and messing about and generating
some features when it went all said and
done basically I've got a little Python
script that will just read in sentences
I just hash the sentence itself just so
that unique identifier is useful to have
and then a whole bunch of numeric
features a classification on the end so
yes so that I've done that in advance
I've got something called features dump
which is basically taking the sentences
dot CSV running it through my features
extractor dumping it out into CSV so
working with that features dump let's
load it in I'll split it into a test and
training dataset so I've got a random
7575 rose for my tendencies in my
training set and 25 in my test set and
then yeah it was like a week's worth of
trying to extract some features and
about I think I'd half an hour on the
train to build a model and test in easy
so I used random forests not a huge
amount in science and how I chose random
forests other than past experience and
it's a classification problem and yeah
and it was easy so
built my vendor price classifier so if I
try predicting from my test set
let's just
so yeah just take my test set run a
prediction with my random forest model I
look at what I've got in my prediction
output I look at this properly the
second in a confusion matrix you can see
actual state man predicted statement
this sentence ID predicted statement
actual statement and then there's a few
that are wrong like that one and you'd
have to map back using that hash ID to
work out what the sentence was so if you
do seem to have a very basic validation
using pandas cross tab I can print out a
little confusion matrix and that looks
pretty good it's so when it end on your
definition of good I mean not our Hut I
kind of quite a few shortcuts with this
and I'd say the training data set wasn't
ideal in a lot of ways and still got
about 90% accuracy in terms of the
prediction is in was it a statement was
it the question was it's chat and you
know if you design your flow of your
chat bot practically that's probably
good enough because you know you can
have built into it as you'll see I have
in a minute so if it gets a statement it
says would you like me to store that for
you
you could sort you can always say no and
then ill you can try putting putting
what you want to say and again you know
in a clearer way and it will get it I
would say that that I mean there are
some flaw I have been studying a data
science with Coursera for three years I
think there are quite a few kind of
flaws and shortcuts in my approach not
not least is the fact that I've
developed the my strategy for the
features against quite a small data set
and then
and then use that same day datasets
testing against so just to kind of make
it a bit more challenging I just went to
the Python faq website and I'm not even
never ready actually and they'd never
read it until it and I tried putting in
statements from the FAQ and questions
from the FAQ into another CSV to see how
my model worked predicting against of
that I also added them some random
statements like what do you reckon you
know here whatever if Anna like I should
show thee I should show the CSB done
load in just waiting
so first question on the FAQ what is
Python Python is an interpreted
object-oriented programming language so
that's all I've done and then I've
loaded load a lot of chat things in to
make it more difficult for it because
chat is challenging right so how do we
do so basically loading all my features
and then use the model that we built
previously and cross-check the
prediction cross-checking accuracy and
not so good
but it still works why so I mean so the
accuracy for chat is pretty low but it's
picking quest it's getting questions and
statements correct about 80% of the time
so you know not bad but I thought it's
also important to kind of illustrate
that yeah the limitations and I'm quite
confident that this could be improved
upon quite a lot this is this is really
a first cut and I just wanted to
illustrate the method and the approach
you know maybe this is a standard way of
doing things but I haven't seen anyone
really talking about it so I thought I'd
add it into the talk ok so that's the
end of I'll so here we could do some ad
hoc testing so anybody wants to give me
a sentence we'll see if we can classify
argue this statement or a question about
anything a fact
that is tricky do you want a question
mark on it or not
okay yes yes
so prediction is question right
so and it's peculiar I won't when I run
it through that sort of validation
method I went to eight it doesn't the
accuracy doesn't look very good but I
presented this to kind of a smaller
group few months ago there was a bit
skeptical and sitting sitting in the pub
people trying to make it go wrong and
people found it frustratingly difficult
and they could go wrong so I'd summarize
it as not bad so I've actually forgotten
actually missed down quite a lot of my
talk I've lost my place where are we in
our lead location
yeah okay so given all that putting it
all together I had a go at constructing
a simple faq chat bot using the sort of
framework described earlier and really
this just takes some human input and
decides am i dealing with a statement
question or chat if it's a statement and
I use the Stanford NLP parser to extract
the tappet the topic the subject and the
object as well as just the bag of words
and store it but store it appropriately
so the words for that statement are
classified on a database table if it's a
question then I go and look for then a
fertile I extract the topic for the
question and then I can go and search
from previously stored statements based
on those topics mainly and subjects and
objects and then finally if it's chat I
can kind of revert back to that example
I showed earlier where it just it
doesn't try to find a statement of fact
so if you just say something your name
to it it doesn't try and tell you about
them
the thinking behind Tyson or the next
Oracle database release date just spit
some chat back at you and this works I
mean this is a complex area and this
works to an extent I can see lots of
flaws in it I can also sort of see how I
could possibly fix them but as a
starting point I mean I think no matter
what people think in the room as a
starting point I think that's a kind of
a good summary of the different pieces
that you need to put together to make a
useful chapter I you need to classify
the type of statement that you're
dealing with and then if you're storing
that you you need to classify it not
just in terms of what type of word is
this but also its context in the
sentence that it occurred in and
similarly when you retrieve information
you need to do that so I've not even
considered attempting natural language
generation that looks like a hugely
challenging thing to do it's a lot and
it's amazing how much if you've got say
10 colleagues in your workplace
typing stuffing it's amazing how much
natural language just builds up in the
system anyways it's a lot easier to just
try and spit back something else that
someone already put in but you know if
you're if you've got like a hundred data
scientists working on it or whatever
then you could you know using the
mechanisms I think that are there in the
standard NLP core package and some much
cleverer machine learning algorithms are
the ones I've been using it as possible
so you know how did they go on so on my
github page in the readme which I've
lost
I've kind of got a pre-canned example
which shows kind of how well it works
and what it looks like when it doesn't
work very well where is it here we go
so here we go I say hi as hello
the latest Python source distribution
Yeti Oh together
shall I still that as a fact yes thanks
I made a note of it is another fact all
right so I say here I say there is a
Python news group etc it stores that now
I say where can I get the latest item
source code from can't find an answer to
that because at the end of the day we're
still doing searches on words for
retrieving the statements and answer to
questions so when I ask the question a
different way where is the latest Python
source distribution then it tells me so
that it works to an extent and you know
I can see there's various ways that
could be evolved either by just storing
questions it couldn't answer and then
you could get it to ask people that are
knowledgeable on that topic the answer
for its questions or you could go down
the route of storing associated words
and mapping those across it's quite a
complicated thing to do so finally I
think if people are interested I've got
a I've got this chat box server running
on a little for CPU Oracle cloud VM
which it'll connect up to it maybe as an
experiment we could everybody could try
and put in two or three statements
things you've learned today and you can
try asking back if everybody did that
you could try accessible asking back
your own question we go to try and
retrieve your own statement back again
and then you could try asking something
else back and if there's enough kind of
volume of input maybe it'll be
interesting or maybe it'll just crash my
VM your family so I put some details up
on how to do that I pre created a slide
why did I do it like that
hmm
so unfortunately I lost the notes to the
IP address so you have to bear with me a
second
right
so anybody's going to do this could you
first
could you make a note of that IP address
before I am change screens and do
something else what if I am I don't like
it's not visible okay that's a better
idea
so there's no authentication
it's a server listening on port 999 and
[Music]
to access it you need
I should explain one of the reasons I'm
a little bit chaotic is I was my laptop
failed last night and I was up till 1:00
a.m. reconstructing things
I've lost track of the few files
so probably easier than just copying
that URL down if you just go to that
github repo and look in there is a file
called simple client pie in the releases
if you download that then you can attach
to
ignore the you can attach the chat bot
again PI simple I'm PI then - a for the
host address and call 1.14 for 3.19 - p
for the port three nines
and
there we go
anybody tonight gets connected to it
please tell me cuz the longer it's
working I can't do it myself the one be
able to do I'll be able to see my screen
oh good
I connected and oh great so now just say
hello that's not very good
[Music]
no right what let's see if it works for
me
oh I don't believe it it's not worthy
hello binoculars yeah yeah hello we go
to Reno's all right okay well yes I
picked up all nine one is called Umbach
where you can mess around with tipple
nine one and you can see what a chatbot
with no yeah and in the meantime I'll
see if I can work out what's wrong
really what that was then
at this point
yeah I'm sure I tried it literally an
hour ago it was
I can see lots of people try to attack
soon
yeah okay well I'm sorry about that that
does appear to be the curse of the live
demo one works wonderful I doubt it but
yeah as possible as possible
yeah yeah okay well I better stop in
there so I say thanks very much guys so
it's slightly a flat ending I will still
dictated
[Applause]
[Music]